hello folks welcome to
rational science
directly from frankfurt germany the only
site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does mathematics they do
the movement of concepts
i got a message there from youtube i'm
wondering i hope everybody can see me
and hear me okay okay
and let me know otherwise okay
anyways we've got a great day today
we're going to be doing a little bit of
this this is the rundown we're going to
look at the electric universe there was
an issue raised about the electric
universe and i'm going to be talking a
little bit about this fellow uh wal
thornhill okay
uh
as part of that i'm going to look at
nassim haramain a subject that i
forgot to mention the other day someone
raised the issue and so i'll cover that
briefly
and that's going to lead us into the
topic of today which is what is gravity
okay
and then i'm going to look at the
science critic he made a video
45 minute video uh about the scientific
method and he criticized it so now we're
answering point by point
and uh
the main point there is that he says
uh that no one can understand quantum
mechanics and yes we agree with that
and then we're gonna look at the flat
earthers and now it's six weeks
six weeks
that they do not understand the question
obviously if they do not understand the
question they can't answer the question
and uh
this also means that you know this
explains to some degree why
after 3 000 years no one has been able
to in mathematical
physics mathematics been able to answer
what gravity is okay and either then the
flat earthers obviously
anyways and then we're gonna go uh with
the questions and comments that people
made since last time
okay so moving on here let's look at the
electric universe uh follow raise this
issue he said uh
okay good thank you
uh says there is no one in the electric
universe community that claims gravity
is equivalent to electricity
once you provide a citation
and to me this is ex
incredible that uh someone would say
that
uh it seems to me that some of these
electric universes and and other sects
out there they do not understand their
own religion they go to
i guess uh electric universe
uh
church on sundays you know sunday
schools
and they don't understand what they're
listening to
and here on the right i provide two uh
examples these are just two examples one
is from emanuel
velikovsky russian fellow and uh he's
one of the founders you could save the
electric universe idea a long time ago
and he said in one of his papers says
cosmos without gravitation
attraction repulsion and electromagnetic
circumduction in the solar system okay
and one of his disciples is well
thornhill and he's the head i guess the
main person in the electric universe
today
and he wrote a paper in 2008 uh electric
gravity in an electric universe
so looks like these people are saying
that
gravitation is really electricity okay
so
i just want to establish that first that
this is what the electric universe
uh believes in what they propose this is
their theory that there is no
gravity
out there
it's really all electricity okay that is
their argument
okay um
what's the issue and for this you you
got to look a little bit about the
history of the electric universe and uh
i want to first establish that walt
thornhill who is the head of the
electric universe today right
he uh was in contact with velikovsky
first and also with another fellow uh
his name was ralph sansbury
and
these people
proposed
and while thornhill still proposes
that
that gravity is really electricity
more so than that more important than
that to answer this false question
uh they say there is no such thing as
gravity
okay because gravity itself
is electricity
that's the argument okay so here we go
uh first uh
uh walt thornhill uh had a
video uh done in 2017 one of the uh
conferences the electric universe had
and in it he brings uh he he presents
uh velikovsky and he talks about the
fact that velikovsky
wrote a
book that i guess he gave also to walt
thornhill
titled worlds in collision
and says there uh velikovsky's
astrophysics that's the title of the
video you can look it up in youtube and
he says there gravitation is an
electromagnetic
phenomenon okay so i think that's quite
clear there they're saying that there is
no really no real gravitation it's
electricity or electronic magnetism okay
i just want to establish point by point
here first we're going to say that
uh what these people are saying
you cannot yet say at this point right
you cannot say that there is no gravity
according to the electric universe but
what we are saying for sure so far
is that
the electric universe says that gravity
the one at least in our local area our
solar system
is electricity that's what they're
saying okay
and we're gonna go beyond that okay but
let's first establish that point okay
here is um
why uh
while thornhill followed
uh mr
and
he says the following says one of the
tests of a good hypothesis
because it's not a theory until it's
being tested experimentally or
observationally is
the more outrageous yet correct a
prediction is
the more weight it should carry in favor
of that hypothesis
and velikovsky predicted that and he
goes on giving an example about venus
okay
which is not relevant the issue here is
that no a hypothesis first of all is not
a theory which is what he thinks it is
that's where he starts failing that's
where the electric universe starts
failing and the other one is that in
science we do not do predictions and we
do not test anything we do not do
experiments
let me repeat that someone says you may
have misspoken no no in science we do
not do experiments i hope that's very
clear okay and we do not observe we do
not gawk
okay what we do in saints is explain
we explain experiments and we do and we
explain our observations
if you have not explained you're not
doing science okay so if you just
described that what you did in an
experiment or what you observed you
haven't done science
and that's where uh walt thurnhill
already fails he's got the foundations
of his uh electric universe already on
the on the wrong footing okay
and so uh yeah and we don't do
predictions again we don't do
experiments we do in a hypothesis is not
an untested theory one that or one that
requires evidence of any kind that's not
what a hypothesis is
so uh mr thornhill already starts on the
wrong footing because he's got the
uh
scientific method uh wrong
it's his notion of the scientific method
is irrational a lot of that has to do
that with the fact that no one in the
last 3000 years defined
unambiguously what the scientific method
is okay
and when they put things such as
equations they put things like
experiments
uh and predictions and observations and
all these other things that they put in
there over the years
well for sure it's irrational
because you know i can run an experiment
here's an experiment i let go of the
spoon falls to the floor okay
and so i ran the experiment
is that does that make me a scientist
because
i ran an experiment
i can even do it repeatable do it again
okay just in case okay repeatable
experiment there it is am i a scientist
because i observed the spoon fall
obviously you know it's just observation
and we're running experiment we have not
done
science science requires that you
explain for example why the spoon drop
what caused it to drop and that's the
type of questions people for example in
quora ask all the time you know what
causes gravity that's what people want
to
know that's what they want to understand
and that's where we have a problem today
okay we don't have answers to those
types of questions therefore the
scientific method that they've been
using for the last 400 years does not
address those questions
okay
uh so here is what science is not okay
versus what science is science is not
skepticism okay
uh people say oh yes scientific
skepticism no no no such monster okay
there is no skepticism in science
science that you can criticize you know
but that doesn't make you a scientist
this is like saying that you're a boxer
because you're
a reporter who's sitting in the uh
audience and you're watching
you know the fight and you criticize the
flight you say well he shouldn't hit him
with a right he should have hit him with
a left or should have been faster should
have ducked
that's not a boxer that's a reporter
okay so the fact that you're a critic
does not make you a scientist the
scientist is the guy who's in the ring
fighting okay the boxer that's the boxer
and that's what a scientist you gotta
you have to go in there with a theory an
explanation and defend it against
someone who attacks it
okay that's a scientist so none of these
things observing measuring equations
predicting
doing experiments uh testing repeating
the experiment you know repeatable
uh presenting evidence verifying
persuading none of that has to do with
anything with science forming clubs you
know some organization uh making money
off of it uh giving out prizes none of
that has anything to do with science
okay that's all some of it is politics
some is religion you know which is
synonymous politics okay
science explanations and it's got to be
a rational explanation otherwise it's
not an explanation it's an explanation
perhaps in ordinary speech
that does not make it a an explanation
for the purposes of science
okay so uh here's uh mr walt thornhill
and he met mr ralph sansbury sometime a
few
some couple
decades ago at least okay this is what
mr sandsberry says okay he he was also
one of you can say the uh
proponents of the electric universe so
if you want to know whether electricity
is gravity and gravity is electricity
well he's the right man in the sea in
fact that's where walt thurnhill got a
lot of his information one of the things
that stansberry said is he explained
magnetism and gravity as the response of
the orbitally structured electron and
proton to the electric force
mr sanctuary thought that gravity was
really
uh electricity okay and that's what he
explained here's another uh
evidence piece of evidence for that you
know
okay here it is
uh this comes out of uh thornhill's uh
paper
uh
just i think uh an informal paper but
it's online
from 2008 electric gravity in an
electric universe and this is what mr
thornhill says he says the force of
gravity is a manifestation of the
electric force gravity is due to
radially oriented electrostatic dipoles
inside the earth's protons neutrons and
electrons he got that from samsberry and
there's the uh
reference okay
and then
he ends uh his
paper saying gravity is an electric
dipole force between subatomic particles
on the right you see a little drawing
you can look that up what it's all about
but i'm just going to point out
the what's
there underline you know the
like magnets that are free to rotate all
the electric dipoles in protons neutrons
and electrons line up to produce
gravity okay
so this is what sansbury uh came up with
and this is what uh mr thornhill
inherited he subscribed to that
notion and that's what the electric
universe has today okay but let's get to
the bottom of it okay
this all said yeah but uh no one says in
the electric universe
that
uh gravity's actually electricity like
you know there is no such thing as
gravity
right that's that's i think what he was
referring to when he asked that question
okay
and so here it is
this comes from the book this is one of
the main books of the electric universe
a beginner's view of our electric
universe by mr tom finlay and he says
the following he starts out by saying
what uh the argument presented by the
electric universe that the
electromagnetic force is way
uh stronger than gravity okay so they
say look it's much
you know so many
magnitudes greater than gravity so we
have to look at electromagnetic force
because you would not be able to explain
gravity here in the low
solar system uh with this puny
uh force known as gravity
but then they contradict themselves
because you know if if you listen to
that you would say okay it looks like
there's a difference between the
electromagnetic force and gravity
according to the electric universe and
now all these other statements say
exactly the opposite there is no
difference between gravity and
electricity in fact
gravity itself
is really electricity according to the
electric universe so it says the
this fellow finlay says the phone says
those who had dedicated their lives to
scientific research based on gravity
have wasted their time
gravity is a manifestation of the
electromagnetic force
radio gravity itself is fundamentally
electrical and just another aspect of
the electromagnetic force
the four fundamental forces the weak and
strong nuclear forces
electromagnetism
and gravity will all eventually be seen
as having their common root in the
electromagnetic force
according to the electric universe there
is no such thing as gravity because
everything absolutely everything in the
universe is electricity
and then you have the problem of you
know hold it i thought you said first
that electricity was so much more
powerful than gravity and now you're
telling me that gravity itself is
actually ultimately
electricity else
okay so yes that is
the theory that the electric universe
proposes they have no respect whatsoever
for gravity they have no idea what
gravity is they don't care for it they
never talk about it except to
uh criticize it
150 percent of the electric universe is
electricity and they under all
circumstances
deny that there is
such a thing as gravity out there
okay so i hope that's settled i mean you
know uh it's up to other people to come
up with
um
you know
why they think uh
differently to that
okay um so why is the electric universe
irrational well here's a rundown a quick
one that i just wrote the other day i'm
going to go through it real quickly
gravity is electricity that's already
irrational uh electricity has absolutely
nothing to do with gravity other than
the fact that they're both mediated by
the electromagnetic road then yes you
could say that revenue is related to
electricity and to magnetism or
electromagnetism if you will
the issue there is that they're two
different phenomena anyways even under
the road model okay
uh what what's the problem the big
problem is they can't even define the
word electricity and i talked about that
the other day i'm not going to go
through that again but you can look up
the previous two videos where i
discussed that
and uh what is electricity according to
the electric universe well it's some
kind of river
that's the way they envision it
and so the question is if it's a river
are we talking about the water or the
flow
so you know
water is made out of molecules and all
these molecules are flowing downwards
and they're moving right and we call
that a river moving water okay
so when we say
river are we referring to the water or
as the thing are we referring to the
flow what the water is doing
i hope you can understand the difference
there okay and we say rivers both
right well electricity is both
electricity is both the
the electron beads
and the flow of these
things these beads
so when we say that we have electricity
right are we talking about the bead the
electron bead which is the object in
this case or are we talking about the
flow
okay which which are we referring to
electricity is both electron flow
according to the official version
according to the electric universe okay
so you can't say that electricity itself
moves or does anything you can say the
electron bead
does something but you can't say the
electricity moves or does this or does
that because electricity is already flow
it's already in motion electricity is a
dynamic concept meaning electron flow
that's what that's what electricity
means the word electricity means that
electron flow so you can't say the
electron flow flows
okay which is what the electric universe
does constantly they say electricity
flows or moves or goes from one
region to another from one pole to
another you can't say that in science
you can say the electron bead moves but
you can't say the electricity flows okay
and that's where we have a problem it's
more than semantics it has to do with
the fact that these people treat
electricity is a physical object and
when you say it's not a physical object
they say why don't you stick your
fingers in an outlet and you'll find out
if it's an object because i guess that's
the way the electric universes determine
objects they say look you know you want
to see if an elephant is an object go
touch him and if he
kicks you with his trunk
then you know it's uh it's an object
that's the way they determine and in the
case of electricity they say what we do
we stick our fingers in an outlet and if
it gives us a shot we know that
electricity is an object that's the way
they determine it there again totally
irrational
okay they invoke discrete planetary atom
uh that quantum bequeathed to them they
used that planetary atom to explain
ionization electricity the whole works
so
it turns out that they built these
filaments
which uh they say interconnects the
universe
but it turns out that the filaments
themselves are built by electricity
which is what the flow
of electron beads
in one direction actually
and so the question is how can you unite
how can you bind how can you connect the
universe with
discrete particles that are flowing in
one direction
so these filaments are misconceived they
have not uh
you know define them very well they like
to talk about the filaments and they
show you pictures but then when you go
to the nitty-gritty and say well what is
a filament well they say it's a flow of
electricity
which already is wrong you can say it's
a flow of electrons they go in one
direction only and one question there
that pops up you know which sun is the
positive in which star is the negative
pole
yeah and what the electricity travels at
the
speed of light maybe and uh
that's what connects the universe
so yeah a discrete universe that the
electric universe inherited from quantum
mechanics
uh is just as irrational as anything
coming out of quantum mechanics okay all
the physical interpretations are bunk
that's essentially it
okay then they treat plasma as an object
as a thing
and that takes two years to explain to
to electric universer that plasma is not
a thing
like electricity plasma is a flowing
river
in other words a river that has
something that is flowing
right it's a thing that flows that's
what plasma is okay there is no
standalone
object called plasma
and let me prove it to you
okay i'm going to prove it to you here's
uh
they say uh plasma is the fourth state
of matter that's that's what the
electric universe is like the one of the
definitions that they have one is the
fourth state of matter and so we have
solids uh liquids and gases and then
they say there's a fourth state of
matter
and that's known as plasma
okay so what's the issue the first issue
is that you know um
uh state the word state refers to what
something does
it has does not have to do with what
something is
okay so if i show you a table
i say that's an object that's standing
still right there you know and it's not
really moving at that specific moment in
which i point to it
okay
the table in fact even if i don't point
to it the table is there and it has
shape all on its own it's standing there
okay
and so the issue is that
you know there is no motion essentially
of the table i can take a snapshot of
the table and say that's a table okay
point to it and the elect the e.t you
know the klingon that's next to me he
understands the word table because i
point and he's he recognizes what the
word identifies he says okay that object
there that's called tape
that's how it works okay so here we
point okay and we have a box okay and we
call that a solid
is the word solid ace a physical object
no solid is a category okay solid is a
category you have many solids uh boxed
under that heading known as solid okay
i point and i say liquid and i can point
take a picture of a liquid okay which i
threw right out of my spaceship and that
blob there you know that has shape you
can see that it has shape okay and we
call that a liquid some kind of liquid
blue living it could be water okay but
freeze immediately but what you see is
something that has shape okay
obviously i can also throw gas outside
my window okay
and uh i don't know where this isn't
coming out
i don't understand why some of my uh
pictures are not coming out lately
anyways there's a gas you can have gas
as well okay
but uh and we all know pretty much it's
just a bunch of um
atoms okay at a certain distance you can
throw them out of your spaceship as well
i hope this one comes out and here's
okay there's your gas okay but you can't
do the same thing with plasma because
plasma is always moving plasma is
ionized gas
ionized is something in motion ionize
means according to the official version
then an electron leaves the uh
atom it could be acquiring one let's go
with the one that leaves the atom okay
so
the electron leaves the uh atom and
suddenly that atom is ionized that's
what ionize mean but plasma is a process
plasma is a process where you strip an
electron from an atom okay that's what
plasma is that's how it's defined
and uh you know these people say no
plasma is a physical object because i'm
staring at a physical object
no i'm not i'm staring at a movie
of something in motion i don't have to
do the same thing with solid liquids or
gas i can take a snapshot of solid a
liquid or a gas
and i will have something
in the
photograph okay i can't do the same
thing with plasma because as soon as i
take a picture of it it's no longer
plasma because plasma has to be moving
has to be ionizing
it's a process that is in motion
whatever i take a picture of is not
plasma i've taken picture of maybe a
bunch of atoms maybe a gas but certainly
not plasma plasma has to have the word
ionized in it it's part of the word
plasma okay so if i take a picture of
the plasma i'm taking a picture of
ionized gas but not ionized because
ionize means motion therefore it's not i
haven't taken a picture of ionized gas
ionized gas is a movie okay
it's a film
plasma is a film therefore it's not a
stand alone object and yeah it's uh
one of the issues that we have is that
uh the
uh
electric universes don't understand that
argument and they say well bill what
you're doing is a lot of semantics they
they uh
you know
dismiss all that as semantic arguments
and yeah what can i say
uh science is 100
150
uh
semantic here's one fellow who
criticized me and he says i think you're
taking your semantics a bit too far you
need to bring it down a few notches
otherwise you'll never be taken
seriously it's too much
and uh yeah what can i say uh that is
exactly what uh science is science is uh
150 semantics okay and people say well
you know i i don't want to do cement i
came here to do physique i didn't come
here to do grammar or learn english or
whatever
science you need to define so that you
can communicate your ideas and you say
well you know i don't know what plasma
is but let's continue i'm going to treat
it as an object and i've never defined
it but i'm going to continue you can't
do that in science we need to know what
plasma is we need to know what ether is
we need to know what all these words
mean exactly
before we move on before you can begin
your presentation
and so these people don't like
definitions because it destroys their
religion that's the primary reason
okay
okay a couple more problems with the
electric universe uh they introduce uh
metaphysical uh metaphysics uh jargon in
other words
it's the mathematicians who have fed the
language to the masses to the layman and
to people like the electric universe and
others uh flat earthers and stuff
especially you know and they use the
words
that they were taught in high school and
college
uh and what are those words those words
are you know words of mathematics
they're not words of physics they're a
word of mathematics such as energy mass
force field time those are all words of
mathematics they have nothing at all to
do with physics nothing at all we don't
use those words in four letter words in
physics okay so please don't bring any
of those words to explain anything in
physics because they have nothing at all
to do with physics
okay so that's the issue
and uh the other problem with the
electric universe they propose
experiments and because they've been
taught the
irrational scientific method that they
inherited from the mathematicians of the
17th century and they're just following
that
irrational scientific method so they
think experiments predictions and all
this stuff has something to do with
science it don't
period okay has nothing to do with
science uh and then just like all the
others they criticize the establishment
because it censors them but they do
censorship as well so
uh that's everybody does censorship as
far as i know out there
okay one good thing about the electric
universe not all bad is uh here this
comes also from mr thornhill while
thurnham
and what he says that the universe
according to him is connected
sounds a lot like uh mr um
haramain which i'm gonna talk briefly
next but he says the universe is
connected
and what does he connect it with well he
connects it with electrical force
electric force he connects it he says
since all manner in the local universe
is connected in real time so he says
it's connected what he connects it with
he connects it with all these con
concepts okay
he talks about instantaneous motion
he says uh electrons exchange energy
instantly instantly is an irrational
term there's no such thing as instantly
in physics
instantly is a word that belongs also to
mathematics to
the religion of mathematical physics
it's it's an instant it's just one frame
of the film that's what instant is there
is no motion in instant
okay it happened
now in the cross section of time in one
frame of the universal movie that's an
instant okay there is no interval
called instant okay and so these people
want to say instantly like motion
happen in one frame of the film that's
what they're saying when they say
instant or happen instantly
no such monster in physic in physics you
either have one frame of the film or you
have many you have many it's called a
film and it's not instant okay if you
have a single one then you call you can
call that an instant okay cross-section
of time
now
all these synonyms that's what an
instant is
okay so when these people talk about
electrons exchange energy instantly
they're saying there's motion
but it happens so fast that it all
happens in a single frame of the movie
that's what they're saying
and again they don't even understand
what they're saying that's the issue
and then uh yeah so
he says uh all atoms are uh connected
somehow the universe is connected but he
connects them with what electric force
energy
concepts that's what he connects them
with
and yeah that does remind me of mr uh
haramain
nasim haramin i talked about it about
him last time
and uh phil says about naseem which
he brings up he says i have opened the
third eye
he opened his third eye okay i don't
know what planet he came from but he
said he's got a third eye okay
after that all inspiring experience i
sampled shrooms and am open to ayahuasca
i would love to party with nassim
yeah i guess uh if he's got a third eye
and
drugs himself i guess uh
that must uh
you know make him horny
so
so nasim better watch out he doesn't
know all the admirers he's got out there
anyways uh this fella says he says
nassim
um and this is what i forgot last time
he uh makes his money apparently he says
is our crystal's providing substantial
income due to an overwhelming market
and yeah that i can believe that nassim
is more into that than into science than
to physics okay now some people say uh
bill you're uh you're taking too many
liberties in fact i think it's a nest
fellow up here
he says the following he says
you overstep when you pretend to know
people's motivations for doing the work
they do there's nothing incompatible
with making money and doing work you
believe in
yeah okay nothing wrong with that the
only thing is my take on this is a
little different
in the case of naseem i think that mr
nasim
is not so interested in science
especially after his
only paper that he published in 2013
went nowhere especially with the
establishment and because it went
nowhere uh
mr nassim had me he branched off okay
into other things he created this
resonance science foundation
and this is my take on him again my
personal opinion i think he's an ascetic
only in the sense that he introduces
spiritualism and transcendentalism into
physics
he certainly is not this uh dispensed
with a frugal lifestyle
uh
you know
characterized by what renunciation of
material possessions and physical
pleasures
uh i think uh mr nassim haram is more a
businessman than he's a scientist i
don't think he cares about science at
all especially today okay he knows he
can't get his stuff through the
establishment you know
he's trying to say that the world is
connected and again he doesn't tell us
what it's connected with maybe if he
could tell the establishment what is
connected with the establishment would
maybe take interest in what he's got to
say but since he he's just repeating
what uh the buddhists and the hindus
have said for thousands of years saying
that you know the universe is connected
it's all uh
intertwined somehow
but they never explained with what what
physical entity interconnects the
universe mr haramein hasn't said so
either and neither has mr wall thornhill
for the electric universe they all talk
about interconnection uh filaments
everything being connected bounded
binded you know bounded
and
and none of them tell you with what
what is it that interconnects us
and that's what this site is about we
are the first site that says what what
you know a physical entity a what what
interconnects the universe that's where
we differ from all these other folks
okay
so let's move on to um
gravity
see what gravity is uh
you know um
what what gravity is what is gravity i
mean
we talk about gravity and we see the pen
i'm sorry the uh spoon fall to the floor
and we say yeah that's gravity
and that's as far as we go we don't know
what it is what caused it to
to do that i mean if you see someone
pulling on a donkey you say well i know
what caused the donkey to move forward
it was the fact that this guy was
pulling on a rope
okay so we know what caused
the uh donkey to move forward okay
and it's straightforward and you know
you know it's just self-evident
but when you say look what caused this
to fall to the floor we say well i don't
know and but it happens all the time
and we call it gravity and that's it we
have a name for it but we don't have any
explanation for it we don't have a
physical interpretation
after 3 000 years okay
and what is the issue the issue is that
the only issue
the reason no one has an explanation is
they cannot see or touch
the mediators that cause this to happen
that's the that's the only reason see if
we could see we had god's eyes and we
could see what's there
whether something pushing or something
pulling we would say okay that's
straightforward something's pulling on
it or something pushing on it and it's
this because i can now see it i can make
it visible for you
but as long as it remains invisible and
untouchable
you know it's it's stumped all the
researchers throughout history
and that's the only reason we cannot
explain it because we cannot see or
touch the
mediators but what's the issue the issue
is if you cannot if if you do not
mentally
put in there
some visual some
entity some things
some objects
then you're explaining this with black
magic you're explaining gravity with
black magic
okay so you're saying it just happens by
black magic by remote control the earth
pulls on it somehow or maybe the moon
pushes it on it somehow
all you're saying is that there's remote
control
god is doing it the angels are doing it
you know and what mathematical physics
has done all these years is put concepts
in there and they say it's force it's
field it's mass
and then the flat earther said no it's
density
you know they have all these words and
they don't realize none of them are
physical objects we need to know what
physical object is pulling or pushing on
the spoon if you do not put a physical
object pushing or pulling
you are essentially explaining this
phenomenon with black magic so you
cannot use words such as density mass
gravity
uh
force field
concepts you cannot put concepts to
explain that for now
that's the bottom line and so that's
what we have today we have just concepts
so people are explaining it with black
mansion
and so one fellow asks about my site he
says how about you bill okay so uh
apparently he wasn't familiar with what
we do here okay so he has to follow he
says you explain that every atom is
interconnected to every other
uh other atom in the world correct
that's what we're saying in the universe
not only our world like you know our
planet the entire universe
every atom in the universe is connected
to all others okay i want to make sure
that's clear okay
what is the physical nature of the
interconnection of all atoms which pulls
on all other atoms
okay that's the question and he wants
answers specifically what is causing
that force which binds all objects
together in a pool
repeat more or less the what he wants to
know okay science without
experimentation is only philosophy
well there he's totally wrong again he's
got the wrong scientific method the
irrational scientific method he's saying
that if i run an experiment okay and i'm
going to run an experiment and
there it is there's the experiment i
threw or i let go
of the spoon okay i'm not throwing in
i'm just letting go of it okay and it
always falls to the floor by magic
and he's saying uh without
experimentation well i did an experiment
so what is this just philosophy
people want to know or understand right
what causes this to fall and he's saying
that's philosophy if you don't if you
don't do an experiment well i'm doing an
experiment you know and so
uh does that make it physics because i
did an experiment
so again he's got the irrational notion
of what an ex what science is okay what
physics is
another fellow uh similarly uh asked
about this site he says bill which
theory do you follow on the mechanics of
cosmology
and i guess he's referring to
maybe i mean electric universe flat
earth
um uh
quantum mechanic not quantum here but
general relativity string theory you
know he's talking about cosmology
talking about the big picture how the
universe works gravity at the universal
level right and so he wants to know how
that works uh according to you know
which one i subscribe to and the first
thing i want to make sure i don't
subscribe to any of those okay don't
subscribe to flat earth i do not
subscribe to electric universe general
relativity strengthy or even quantum
mechanics which is not a cosmological
theory but i don't subscribe to it
either
none of those have anything to do with
rationality with with physics with
science with anything
all those are irrational therefore they
have nothing to do with science so i
don't subscribe to any of those okay
but i do have something to
propose in the alternative and that's
what this site is about okay and yes it
has to do with interconnectivity
because we're going to show that
gravity is not an action-added distance
phenomena
gravity is
just like any other phenomenon the only
difference between
regular everyday phenomena is that we
can't see the mediators we can't see or
touch the mediators that's the only
issue if we could see and touch them it
would be kindergarten stuff you would
say okay i see what's causing this
something is pulling on it which is on
our theory we're saying there's a pool
there okay
but you know as long as you don't see
anything there and you're expecting to
see or touch something you say let's go
to the lab let's run an experiment let's
use our eyes and our hands
to detect what's causing this
and you're an irrational individual
because mother nature father universe
god the devil whoever you believe in
they don't do gravity with visible and
tangible things
their mediators are invisible and
intangible their things their objects
their entities
but they're not visible or touchable
and until you grasp that you're gonna
chase your tail around forever that's
the story from this site okay
so let's go with what um
what someone proposes here and that's
quantum mechanics in general or you
could say
it's really
mathematical physics in general i put
quantum mechanics but because that's the
one that deals at the microscopic level
but really this is uh
all of mathematical physics and in fact
this is what they have proposed for 3
000 years what you see there on the left
hand side is discrete particles just
forming
part of the vacuum some some people
equate it with a vacuum some say
that the particles are floating in the
vacuum okay in space okay there's these
two versions out there but what you're
staring at is the ether okay
the ether is a bunch of discrete
particles that form the backdrop to
everything out there in the universe
that's what the ether is that's how the
the greeks conceptualize it and nothing
has changed in 3000 years anyone who
says that ether is anything other than
what you see there a bunch of particles
uh does not know what the ether is and
so the onus is on that person to one of
the two either draw
you know illustrate
take a photograph make a mock-up of a
statue or whatever of the ether
or define the word ether unambiguously
if he cannot define the word ether
unambiguously he cannot even start his
presentation we need to know exactly
what the ether is and whether the ether
is equivalent to space vacuum nothing or
whatever you want to call it or whether
the ether meaning these particles or
whatever the ether is
is inside
you know it's uh contained so to speak
within the within space in other words
if ether and space are two different
things or the same thing that's what we
want to understand before he can start
his presentation we need to know if it's
a physical object or if it's an abstract
concept a concept is something you
define
an object is that which you can point to
because it has shape
and if it has shape there should be no
reason for anyone to have an excuse
to say that they can't draw it they
can't illustrate it
on the other hand what do we propose the
rope hypothesis there you have it
interconnected atoms all atoms in the
universe are connected
bound to each other by something that is
there that we cannot see or touch in
fact we cannot see atoms
you know so so for people to request to
see
the mediators that bind two atoms it's
irrational because we cannot even see
atom no one has ever seen a hydrogen
atom let alone what interconnects two
hydrogen atoms okay so until you get a
grasp of that alone you know you got a
long ways ahead of you you know because
you don't understand half of it yet
okay so what happens here we have two
atoms okay
and
you can see what quantum mechanics
essentially mathematical physics
proposes okay and that's the
quantum atom you have a little ball in
the center called the proton they call
it a positive particle we don't know
what positive is
okay positive is just the opposite of
negative they could have said it's the a
or the z they could have said that it's
a west or east they could have said
north and south they could have said any
two
opposite so you could say it could have
called one the yes and the other one the
no that's what positive and negative
really mean we don't have an
idea from the mathematical establishment
what positive and negative mean in
physical terms so they put a plus sign
and a negative sign these ridiculous
symbols to say they're opposite whatever
opposite means in physical terms
and so that's the atom and a little
red ball that's called the electron it's
supposed to
go around or somewhere around the proton
and that's why those dotted lines
essentially
uh it's an orbit
and they call that orbit an orbital that
they have
converted the region in which you can
find an electron bead they call that an
orbital so the region which is a concept
has been turned into a physical object
some kind of shell of sorts okay like an
egg shell
and then
one atom can influence another one
through what they call entanglement or
through gravity or through whatever
action at a distance they that they want
to talk about
and what is action at a distance there
is no mediator between two atoms these
are all discrete
particles they are discrete atoms and
even within the atom we have discrete
particles that we have no idea what
binds them together we have no idea why
the electron doesn't spontaneously leave
the
atom or why does it doesn't fall towards
the nucleus why does it
uh
remain in a region known as the orbital
okay that or energy level that's what we
want to understand and we don't have an
answer to that and uh mechanics the
quantum mechanic people you know they
just say we don't understand it either
but let's continue okay that's the way
it works and a lot of people think that
they do understand and because otherwise
we wouldn't have all the technology that
we find out there okay on the bottom you
see the rope hypothesis we have a
physical mediator
a physical mediator okay
and that means that
one atom is bound to the other
physically so they can't
leave
you know like one atom can't leave the
universe or the space first because
space
is nothing
a synonym of nothing that means it has
no shape nothing can leave that which
has no shape you have no border to cross
that's one reason but even assuming uh
space had a border you know surface uh
the atom couldn't leave it because it's
bound to all other atoms in the universe
right
and so that's the
you can see the difference there our
atoms are bound their atoms are not and
our atoms have this uh three-dimensional
atom that you see there it's a
essentially
made of the same thread that forms the
rope okay that's why it's called the
rope hypothesis and one of those threads
uh goes around and forms the electron
shell and all the uh threads from every
atom in the universe weave around and
comprise the electron shell while the
other thread that forms the rope goes
right through the center of the atom and
forms what we call the proton dandelion
or star okay so we have all this uh all
these uh
threads
that form the elect the atom itself okay
so not only do they form the rope but
the atom that's built from the same
threads so that's the uh proposal okay
and here we see them in motion okay
okay you have the
uh quantum mechanics version up there we
have a little ball that somehow falls
between these two
uh energy levels doesn't fall all the
way to the center of the atom
which is that blue ball which they call
the proton okay
and at the same time it doesn't leave
the atom itself unless it's ionized
forming what is going to be called
plasma a bunch of atoms which are ins
that's plasma okay and again they have
this action at a distance
it's black magic that's what action at a
distance stands for whenever you hear
that you you hear black magic because
they're saying there's no mediator but
one atom influences another even if it's
at the other side of the universe that's
what these people tell you okay
okay and at the bottom you see our model
and that is that the atom is a membrane
which we call the electron shell which
encapsulates the proton star okay
and all of this is made of the same
thread as the rope which binds any two
atoms an atom can approach another one
and it does so by swallowing
thread from the rope okay so as it pumps
back and forth which is what we call the
quantum jump
it approaches another atom by sliding or
like a beat on an abacus essentially you
know it doesn't take the wire with it
and this is more or less the same thing
an atom just approaches another atom
eating
uh rope
as it approaches the other one until for
example they can form the h2 molecule
which means that
uh the there is no more rope between
them what we have at that point is just
the merged shells okay so this is
the proposal this is what we propose in
exchange for quantum mechanics and
mathematical physics in general
okay
okay so uh one fellow brings up and he
uh summarizes essentially the
version cosmological version that
mathematical physics has
for gravity which is what we're talking
about right here okay and this is it he
says general relativity einstein's
theory of gravity is the geometric
theory of gravitation geometric because
they say it's the uh
modification the distortion
of
space-time which is supposedly this
four-dimensional medium okay an ocean
think of it like that okay but it's a
four-dimensional
ocean that's how they're going to
illustrate it okay
usually in two dimensions
well two really it's a 3d
uh
projected onto 2d platform that's what
you see there okay
the current description of gravitation
in modern physics yeah
modern mathematics okay
modern mathematical physics which is not
physics at all
general relativity
describes and see he's talking about
description and describing okay yeah
mathematics can only describe and that's
what general relativity is it's a
description
the explanation the physical
interpretation is totally irrational
it's nonsense uh but what the
mathematicians are concerned about is
the mathematical description that's what
general relativity is just a
description that's why they love it so
much okay
describes how properties of the world
change in the presence of sources of
gravity general relativity explains the
laws
now first we have no laws in physics and
certainly general relativity doesn't
explain anything the explanation is
again warped time warp space
and that's not an irrational explanation
meaning it's no explanation at all
it may be an ordinary speech in religion
that could be called an explanation not
in physics not in science an explanation
has to be rational in order to be an
explanation okay so explains the law of
gravitation as relation to other forces
in general in uh in nature okay
so what is
uh
a rational explanation because this is
an irrational explanation therefore it's
no explanation at all this is not an
explanation to say that
time warp okay
time is warped and that's what prevents
the earth from flying out of the solar
system because time is work no way you
can't do that not in physics
okay and so here we have the criteria
for irrationality okay
irrationally the main one is number one
treating concepts as objects okay
redefine objects uh concretization okay
and what they're doing is they're
turning uh words such as field
and uh energy mass
into physical objects and they start
moving these things around they're
saying oh we transferred energy
uh the field is vibrating it's an
excited field
you know and the mass moved and so on no
you can't do that not in science so
those are irrational
uh physical interpretation when you put
a concept you start moving and vibrating
or whatever you do with it
uh using inconsistent or undefined words
you know inconsistent definitions or
undefined words
the theory doesn't follow from the
hypothesis from the assumptions okay the
explanation uh doesn't follow from what
you presented up front you know
describing and claiming to have
explained and uh the mechanism cannot be
even imagined
okay so
whatever
when when um when general relativity
says that
um
uh gravity is the
something to do with space-time you know
uh meaning that um
it's uh
the warpage of space-time or the bending
of time or anything like that those are
irrational explanations and if it's an
irrational explanation you cannot even
imagine it i mean what are you going to
imagine for work time for bent time
what what is that the seconds are bent
is that what these people are saying
okay
and uh so you know maybe uh here you can
see
a little bit of that okay here's
einstein he says he what's the seconds
the time timewarp okay
is is that what we're supposed to
visualize is that is that what we're
supposed to imagine that
uh time is warped meaning the second
maybe it's the minutes the years i don't
know you know whatever unit they you
want to put in there or maybe they're
warping something else maybe they're
maybe they're talking about a different
kind of time like this one you know
money they say time is money
is that what they're talking about is
that what they're warping
all these uh people who are the
disciples of einstein today
okay so yeah this is the problem the
problem is that you cannot say that
you're gonna
uh
do time warps and that that's an
explanation for how the universe works
or why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system okay
and this is this is essentially what
they're saying okay in general
relativity okay that there's a wall of
time it's a curved wall of time and
that's that depression that you see
underneath the sun there so the sun
somehow weighs this down with its mass
because it's not the sun it's the mass
of the sun that's weighing down the
canvas and what is the canvas it's
the length width and height
plus time okay so essentially we we
don't care about length width and height
in this case we're saying that uh what
the mathematicians are saying is that
mass is pushing down the the canvas that
includes time and therefore time is a
wall that prevents the earth or one of
the components
of the space-time thingy that prevents
the earth from flying out of the solar
system
that's what they're saying okay and yeah
it's like the roulette mechanism so you
don't have to be a genius to understand
what these people are saying they're
saying that mass warps space time
meaning time let's forget about space
for a moment it uh warps time and at
warp time is what prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system
obviously it's unimaginable and if it's
unimaginable they don't have a physical
interpretation and the question is why
did they even attempt to give a physical
interpretation if mathematics
mathematical physics
does not
provide physical interpretation if
that's philosophy as they call it in the
end you know when you put them against
the wall they say well that's philosophy
anyways it's opinion so to speak
religion they don't care about it and
you say why did you even attempt to give
a physical interpretation to your
equations if you're going to give an
irrational one and at the end say well
it's just philosophy anymore
see this is the issue the issue is these
people claim to know how the universe
works they don't know how the universe
works they don't understand how it works
and then they say well that's philosophy
anyway that's what where we're at today
okay what's the quantum version because
that's the cosmological version how
about you know this little
uh spoon it falls to the floor okay and
you say well why did that fall to the
floor how does quantum explain this at
the you know everyday level at the micro
level because relativity again is out
there relativity is not used to explain
this okay
and or even describe this there is no
warp space near the spoon so work that
it creates this effect
okay a lot of people don't understand
that they say oh general relativity
explains it no general relativity does
not work
here on earth it works out there at the
micros at the
macroscopic level
so general relativity is a cosmological
theory
not even a theory it's a description
okay
mathematical description but it does not
explain or purport to explain this and
he who doesn't understand that is not
even a relative it doesn't even
understand relativity but yeah this is
the world of quantum mechanics here the
world of everyday life
you know we're talking about the
microscopic level for quantum mechanics
and you have to explain gravity there
but this world here the regular world
has to be explained also in terms of
quantum mechanics not in terms of
general relativity
so how do they explain it at the
microscopic level the sub atomic level
well here it is okay this is
you won't believe it but this is the way
they uh explain attraction in general
okay here's two quarks being pulled
together by a gluon but a gluing is a
particle okay and that's what they claim
it is and so here's a clue
a quart throwing a glue on another quark
but it attracts it there's this
attraction between quarks okay they
don't fly out of the solar system uh
meaning you know the little atom that
little solar system they don't fly out
of there why because the gluon keeps
them together okay so how does a quark
do it well it throws
a um a glue on it another quark and
somehow because the gluon goes outwards
it pulls the
um other quark towards it
that's what it keeps you know the corks
together and you say how is that
possible that doesn't make any sense to
say you throw something at another court
and it pulls on the court how do you
explain that
and here you have a
who died a couple years ago his name is
victor stender
and he's
he was a physicist
and this is what he has to say it says
the vacuum is capable of producing
interactions between particles that
effectively space like separations
and says let me explain no doubt the
idea of motion backward in time makes a
grievous attack on common sense however
to a particle physicist raised on a diet
of finemen diagrams motion backward in
time is not at all that disturbing all
fundamental particle interactions work
backward as well as forward
okay and so these people just do
mathematics
and what they're doing is they're saying
look you know we
to throw a particle at something and
attract it is not um you know not beyond
the mind of a mathematician
and again these people are not doing
physics they're not doing physical
interpretation they just get away with
murder saying it is so and that's it
so all they're doing is saying you know
uh yeah if you throw a stone at a
at a donkey
you attract them
that's what they're saying and you say
well how is that possible how do you
conceptualize that they call it negative
momentum negative momentum transfer you
throw the ball but it delivers
negative motion
in your direction
that's okay mathematically you just
change the sign from a positive to a
negative right that's it and so instead
of having positive uh
you know momentum for example you have
negative momentum
great so now all you did was change the
sign which is a physical issue because
now they're saying look that changed the
direction of motion
there is no such thing as direction of
motion in phys in mathematics okay
so by changing the sign all you did was
uh suddenly you ventured into physics
okay without anyone knowing and say well
i'm still doing math and we have no
problem with that because we change the
sign and suddenly the motion the
direction of motion is in the opposite
direction
that's not math that's jumping over into
physics without any
uh
without substantiating it
and just saying that we change the sign
and suddenly you know the direction of
motion changes
okay again that's a big leap of more
than faith it's
ridiculous okay
okay so here we have it
okay um this is how we explain it
because all atoms in the universe are
physically interconnected
every atom of that astronaut is
connected to every atom on earth every
atom on earth is connected to every atom
of that astronaut and the reason he
accelerates towards the earth is as he
falls
more and more independent ropes are
acting on every one of the atoms in his
body
okay
so as you widen uh
ropes are not on the same axis that's
what's happening they are fanning out
and so you have more what we call
independent ropes tugging on that
astronaut and that's the reason for the
acceleration of gravity we have a cause
a physical interpretation for the
acceleration of gravity okay that's the
that's what we're showing here you say
well is is that true okay
and uh here you see it here's the uh
spoon falling towards earth again okay
and what's happening every atom of that
spoon is connected to every atom on
earth obviously i didn't draw every atom
i didn't draw every rope that's
connecting
all the atoms binding all these atoms
but you get the idea that as it falls
the
ropes are fanning out
okay there are more ropes
that are
in what we call independent rows that
they're not on the same axis anymore
that explains the acceleration of
gravity
okay and so one other question people
say well
how does it work here it is synthesis
okay
so that you can get the idea okay you
have all atoms interconnected between
two objects object one and object two
uh we can talk about their masses in
other words how much they weigh if you
want how many kilograms you got in there
in each one
and uh you have distance separating two
objects the farther away two objects are
from each other like you see there on
the upper right
uh the more they act as one and the
closer they are together you can see
that the ropes are fanning out and you
have more independent rows because they
are not on the same axis this explains
this is a physical interpretation for
the acceleration of gravity
now the ropes don't pull each each rope
does not really pull what you have is
tension between any two atoms the ropes
are only under tension
we use the word pull because we're so
used to seeing one object fall towards
another we say oh one object pulled on
the other but what's actually happening
is the distance shortens because
uh
you know one object as it approaches the
other the ropes fan out and there is no
pull within a rope all you have is
tension that's why you know in newton's
force law we replace the f
force replace it with t for tension and
there is an attention is not a force
only in the religion of mathematics is
uh force uh attention of force in other
words they're synonyms not in science in
physics tension is not a force force if
you look up the definition
uh it'll tell you that someone has to
win the tug of war and that's not the
case of tension uh in the case of force
something has to move in one direction
of another or another in the case of
tension
at least between two atoms bound by a
single rope there is
no
no one wins the tug of war there's
constant tension on it which is in the
tension is
uh defined by the velocity of light
squared which is i'm sorry by the
velocity of light which is a constant in
the universe so that is a measure of the
tension on the roof
okay and you say well where did you get
this well uh we got this from mr muller
here you can not that i got it from him
but he he
reinforces this he says look
uh every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of you you are also pulling
on it the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things okay
so i want every one of you tonight
uh especially if you pray every night
before going to bed
i want you to say the lord's prayer
tonight okay
the lord builds prayer and here's the
lord
bill
prayer and i want you to memorize it
okay so that you can recite it every
night before going to bed okay here it
is okay
uh every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of you
you are also pulling on it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things okay
so i want you to memorize the lord
bill's prayer
and recite it every night so that you
know how gravity works and there you
have the whole key that's the whole
mystery of gravity right there in front
of you okay
every atom of you is pulling out every
atom of the earth and every atom of the
earth is pulling on you
that is the description and explanation
of gravity
okay
we have our science critic
and uh this fellow uh did a little bit
of criticism of the scientific method
and he raised an issue
uh related to quantum mechanics this is
what he's got to say about quantum
mechanics i want you to listen carefully
because he's going to tell you
what he thinks about
quantum mechanics the fact that no one
understands it it's irrational totally
and
and so he's going to kind of reinforce
that right now okay this is what he had
to say give me a second here and i'll
turn it on
here it goes listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
if quantum mechanics is admittedly just
observation and description and beyond
understanding
does it even belong in science
and is quantum mechanics just weird and
tricky to understand
or are the physical interpretations of
quantum mechanics irrational and
therefore
impossible to understand
now something that i don't think a lot
of people realize is that quantum
mechanics is not so much a theory to try
and explain underlying mechanisms of the
universe it's a description of what we
observe
pretty much all of quantum mechanics is
oh we observed this thing that happens
at a small scale
this is what we found and that is why
quantum mechanics is all about
observation and describing what you have
observed so that article that was cited
is about how quantum mechanics is weird
and we don't know why and that's because
quantum mechanics is a very tricky thing
to understand a lot of the observations
that we get don't really make sense to
us but the thing is you cannot just
throw out a whole lot of observations
simply because they're inconvenient to
you if you did that well then you'd be
irrational
okay so that's his point of view he
thinks that
if it's irrational if if if it's
unobservable you cannot even imagine
here you cannot understand it but he
calls that rational
because if you throw it away because we
observe the visible things in the lab if
you throw that away the description
uh
then you're
you're being irrational you should not
throw the observation but the issue is
that we observe the things that we can
see not the things that we can't see
and the things that they can't see you
know the mathematicians
uh the
particle mathematicians what they say is
the things that they cannot see they put
in the blanks for you and they say let
us interpret that for you what's
happening in here that's where we have
the problem we don't have a problem with
the description the mathematical
description where they say look this is
the equation this is how fast something
went this went this is what the mass was
this was the energy we have no problem
with any of that
the issue here is what is the physical
mechanism that
had you know one particle assuming it
was a particle right
hit another one
and you know we can't see what's the
mediators that bring two particles
together we can't see the mediators
between
two quarks we can't see
the mediators during entanglement
and clearly there are no mediators uh
proposed by quantum mechanics for
gravity
so we can't see the mediators and so
these people like this well he just
believes in the establishment yeah but
look the observation is correct
what observation they couldn't observe
what what is invisible why do they even
use the word observe when they cannot
observe what we wish them to observe
which is the mediators
okay so again if you can't observe the
mediators and you put in there
you know by hand you know sort of uh
force
push it in there you know and say well
we know what's happening in there it's a
particle that's mediating that or it's
uh maybe a concept like field or energy
or whatever then yeah then that's where
we have a problem okay
and so um
first let's confirm that you know
quantum mechanics is irrational it's
irrational why because no one even those
proponents of quantum don't understand
it and a lot of people out there don't
understand that the mathematicians don't
understand their own quantum mechanics
this is what people don't understand out
there they say well sure they understand
it otherwise we wouldn't have the
technology we have we wouldn't have
computers right if one of them were
wrong
that's their logic and they say well we
don't understand all that math but they
must be doing something right because
they built all these computers and so
they got to know what they're doing
that's their rationale if you can call
it rationale and so nobody is aware that
the mathematicians have no clue
whatsoever how quantum mechanics works
if they have no clue whatsoever of how
quantum mechanics works
it's an irrational theory whatever they
propose they have to propose a rational
theory that they can understand and pass
on to us okay and so here it is uh here
you have uh dickie feynman okay he says
will
you understand what i'm going to tell
you
and say you think i'm going to explain
it to you so you can understand it
no you're not going to be able to
understand it you see my physics
students don't understand it either that
is because i don't understand it nobody
does while i am describing to you how
nature works you won't understand why
nature works that way in other words the
causes okay the mechanism but you see
nobody understands that i can't explain
why nature behaves in this peculiar way
then he says in another
of his lecture he says i think i can
safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics do not keep asking
yourself if you can possibly avoid it
but how can it be like that
nobody knows how it can be like that the
more you see how strangely nature
behaves the harder it is to make a model
that explains how even the simplest
phenomena actually work so theoretical
physics has given up on that
okay so uh i think he fireman he had no
idea whatsoever what he was doing okay
all they do is equations they do math
but they have no idea how to translate
those equations into physics the it's
the physical interpretation which they
call philosophy when they are put
against the wall
that's what they can't explain it's the
physical interpretations that's that's
where they die
okay so um
here we have uh
what irrational criteria is again one
more time so that we have it treating
concepts as objects reification and
congress concretization using
inconsistent definitions or undefined
words theory is inconsistent with or
doesn't follow from the assumptions
okay describing and claiming to have
explained mathematics does that all the
time they describe because that's all
math can do and they claim to have
explained in the explanation is bunk
it's the
most idiotic thing that you can imagine
but they say well we gave you an
explanation
and we said but that's an irrational
thing yeah we don't understand it either
that's the that's what they tell you
mechanism can't even be imagined okay so
that's that's where
what quantum mechanics is all about
anderson confirmed it so he says they
don't understand it but if they don't
understand it it means what kind of
explanation and what kind of theory is
that theory is an explanation so
physical mechanism that's what it is
what a theory is in physics
if they tell you well we don't
understand them what do you what have we
learned okay that's the issue why can't
they explain well here's a good reason
okay here's the quantum atom okay and
again nobody can explain
the quantum atom no one can tell you why
the atom that you're seeing in front of
you is
like it is in other words it has this
little bead called the electron that
blue little thing that's going around
and what happens it falls to a lower
energy level and then rises to a higher
energy level
both concepts because those are not
physical shells or balloons or anything
like that membranes but what it is just
the electron is simply going back and
forth for no reason whatsoever within a
region around the atom the nucleus okay
so they cannot explain why it doesn't
spontaneously fly out of the atom and
they cannot tell you why it doesn't fall
to the center of the atom that's where
the problem is okay
and uh and because they have this
irrational atom they have irrational
current you know electricity because
what they have is all these electron
beads that are moving from one atom to
another and you say well before you can
explain that tell me what your atom
looks like
and they can't they can't justify their
atom let alone you know why the beads
flow from one atom to another so the the
atom that the
mathematicians have that call themselves
mathematical physicist
um is an irrational atom and therefore
anything based on that atom is also
irrational especially electricity okay
okay so here we have um
uh what's really wrong with quantum
mechanics aside from that that's one
issue but here it is this is just a
quick run down up the top of my head
action at the distance entanglement
totally irrational because anytime that
they have action at a distance that just
means black magic
means they're going to do it with
concepts they're going to put a
mathematical concept there treat it as a
physical object and hope that you don't
notice that you don't realize that okay
no such thing as a weight packet you
know the wave packet says elec
light is both a wave
and a thing of a ball
and so how do you reconcile those in
fact the wave itself
is made out of particles that's what's
moving up and down a bunch of particles
so uh you know the wave packet draw it
once i you dry it or you illustrate it
then i know what you're talking about if
the wave packet is the mediator of light
and then you have other mathematicians
that say well
light does not need a mediator
so what is it that's traveling if you
don't have a mediator
and so they turn it around they they
twist it twist the language they twist
the
question around they say well it doesn't
need a medium through which to travel
what is traveling through a non-medium
what is it that is traveling
so space assuming space is nothing which
ain't in mathematical physics
but let's assume it's totally nothing
meaning there's nothing there absolutely
nothing devoid of particles or whatever
and so they say well
the photon
or the wave packet or the wave
can travel through nothing of space
because it does not need a medium
through which to travel
yeah that's got to do with space with a
medium i'm saying what is the medium
that is traveling through nothing
okay and so the question is not that it
doesn't need a medium through which to
travel the question is what is the
medium that is traveling that's doing
the traveling through nothing okay
so they twist all that around because
they're
you know mental
cases and they don't even understand
what they're saying that's the issue
okay they have particles at two places
at once okay famous
you know uh
superposition and
all these words that they invented out
there
then you have particle is not really a
particle it's a wave function the wave
function collapse that's what a particle
is okay it's a really a field excitation
that's what a particle is the word
particle means in mathematical physics
what is a field is concept that's what a
field is there's no physical object
called field field is just a bunch of
numbers you can look up the word field
yourself and you'll find that it's just
a bunch of numbers okay decreasing
threat strength as
you
leave or get farther away from ground
zero okay for whatever it is gravity
electricity magnetism
accelerate a wave function or a field
which one are you accelerating are you
accelerating the concept field or are
you accelerating the concept wave
function
when you accelerate a particle okay so
this is the issue they're uh refining
all these concepts mathematics does that
all the time uh particle can't uh
produce pull so even if you do have a
particle how do you produce pull with
that particle i mean do whatever you
want with your particle just take the
particle and tell me how you pull with
it
negative momentum transfer is that how
you're going to pull magical just change
the sign and say now change directions
which is an issue of physics not an
issue of math
fume has no gravity to this day they
have cannot explain gravity at all and
they never will you can't explain
gravity with particles so you have to do
what negative momentum transfer you got
to turn it back into a mathematical
nonsense instead of talking about
physics
energy transfer what is that how do you
transfer energy move a mass a wave a
wave etc
uh and besides the wave it's just a
bunch of vectors so whenever you see
that transfer wave all you're seeing is
a bunch of moving vectors which is
another irrationality what they're
illustrating has nothing to do with the
world of physics has to do with
mathematics only
they move a charge and then they have
orbital as a region and they say the
orbitals prevents the electron beam from
flying out of the
atom how can it prevent if an orbital is
a region in a region is a concept okay
so this is the issue they they have all
these irrationalities and they get away
with all that
okay and so here it is um the other the
last point that this fall made
observation description we talked about
and that's got nothing to do with
science in science we don't gawk
observe and we don't describe
you know anybody can describe i can
describe a chair am i a scientist
because of that am i a physicist because
i describe the chair and say well yeah
it's got a seed of back rest and four
legs
mathematics right i described
mathematically is that science because i
describe the chair
and so yeah observation and description
have nothing at all to do with science
science is explanation that's where you
have to break your brain
if you cannot break your brain
explaining something then we have a
problem okay then we know that you are
not a scientist meaning you are not
a
physicist
okay
so let's move on here
uh we had um we had these people known
as flat earthers okay
and um
let's do a little bit of a rundown on
what the issue was
it had to do with the flat earthers not
understanding
what what gravity is essentially that's
what it comes down to okay so here's
flat earth flat earth and gravity okay
and they say it's density they say it's
uh inertia and they use all these
concepts and we don't want concepts we
want to know what pre what physical
object prevents an atom from moving
that's essentially the issue so let's
start at square zero okay
uh we're going to with a frame first
frame of the film okay here it is we
have a van okay and we have a particle
we're going to call that an oxygen
atom or we can call it a molecule i'll
use the word molecule okay so that red
little dot there that's a molecule of
air
okay think of it as that as a single
particle period okay so we have the van
and it's standing still it's part okay
and now this van is going to move okay
so it's going to move and the question
what happens to that particle turns out
the particle stays in the same place
and
the particles that are close to the back
of the van those are going to be pushed
by the back of the band but that
particle the one that's still up front
that particle is not moving so when the
van moves okay the particle stays you
see what happened there okay let me do
that again here's the particle okay just
watch the particle and you watch that as
the van accelerates the particle stays
in place
we got that so far okay
uh
flat earthers uh all these people they
have a lot of problems with that okay
so uh it stays in place and the question
is what caused it to stay in place and
here we are six weeks later and still
they can't understand the question
they can't understand the question
obviously they they won't have an answer
right
okay so um
so here we have it
paul says uh
these are some of the answers that god
showed you that they don't understand
the question and i like this fellow yeah
he went in there and he says i went to
school
okay that's great i'm glad you you told
us that okay that you went to school
yeah apparently he went to a 30 000 a
year royal naval private boarding school
my god
okay he must be a genius okay
and this flat earther says the space in
between those balls are a deceptive
misnomer
non-physical empty spaces have never
been physically proven to exist
he's saying that space does not exist
there's no separation between objects
there are you know uh it's object
against object that's what he thinks it
is ball against ball uh cube against
cube whatever empty space is literally
nonsense
and and this guy went to what he went to
school okay and thirty thousand dollar
year royal navy private boarding school
you know all i can say is please guy
uh go sue that school and tell them that
they jip you they took away you know
your money for at least try to recover
you know your
whatever money you invested in there you
know
they are only a mathematical construct
of the perfect vacuum of space you are
touting non-physical pseudo
pseudoscience concepts which have never
been
experimentally verified even with the
best vacuum chamber on earth
so this poor little fellow you know he
believes that you have to prove the
existence of space otherwise it doesn't
exist and again it has to do with all
these people who talk about proof
evidence experiments testing verifying
none of that has anything to do with
science in science we do not test we do
not do experiments we do not verify
anything okay and science we explain you
have to get in the ring be a boxer you
have to fight you don't you're not the
critic who's sitting in the
you know in the audience and saying well
you should have hit him with a left hand
with a right hand and whatever no the
way it works in science you have to be a
boxer
that's a scientist the guy who's up
there in the ring putting forth a theory
and defending it okay and so this guy
talks about verifying that's religion
verifying his religion evidence is
religion
uh evidence of what a prosecutor uses to
persuade the jury that's called evidence
and that's got to do with persuading
which has nothing to do with science at
all it's got to do with religion we do
not prove in science especially we don't
not prove the existence of space good
luck with that one okay prove the
existence of nothing yeah it's easy
okay so what is the issue well he says
you are avoiding the fact that there is
no gap between the molecules in reality
there is mole there are molecules
throughout you know like the structure
of the atmosphere unless you can explain
what your gaps are why the molecules are
not already touching each other they are
composited from various sized molecules
which you are completely avoiding okay
says i have only ever been dealing with
100 physics of molecules touching
molecules in a fluid sense and then
touching a physical structure of glass
molecules okay structure of a physical
car and structure of physical molecules
of the atmosphere is the only mechanism
available to you in reality he's talking
about the fact that the car pushes the
molecules and the molecules uh you know
are all pushing on each other so he's
saying that the molecule is really that
that i'm talking about the one that i'm
saying stand still he says it stands
still because it's got all these
molecules
not only underneath it but all around it
that keep it in place that's what holds
it in place that's what he's referring
to okay
if you deconstruct the atmosphere adding
gaps everywhere then there would be an
immediately automatic adjustment to fill
those imaginary gaps you added with
molecules it's like swimming in a ball
pit with various sized balls and the big
ones and small ones uh all support each
other
so this fall says there's no such thing
as space
okay
that uh he's got this notion that they
had in the old days uh in the days of
the greeks where as soon as uh
you know you have aristotle believed in
that as well you know that if you move a
molecule another one takes its splice
immediately
so there is no such thing as space
because
it doesn't allow for there to be a space
as soon as one moves another one takes
its place it could be an oxygen molecule
it could be a water molecule it could be
a molecule of a table or whatever object
you know immediately takes that space so
there's no such thing as empty space
according to this fellow which was what
aristotle said a long time ago okay this
is what he's got he's resuscitated for
uh aristotle
okay so let's zoom in okay on that
little picture he had there okay
and there you see the molecules we're
going to consider them as perfectly
round okay they're not even that okay
but assuming they're around
we want to know what the white stuff is
okay
what is that white stuff that separates
one mole that contours each
molecule each atom if you will uh what
is the white stuff that's the million
dollar question if you say there is no
such thing as space which serves as a
backdrop to every single object in the
universe tell me what does what do you
call that thing that separates table
from chair or molecule from molecule or
atom from atom what is that stuff what
is the white stuff that's what we wish
to
understand we want you to identify the
white stuff okay
and
so if you have cubes same thing i mean
you might say well you know they're face
to face they're surface to surface you
got to tell me what separates each cube
otherwise that would be a single block
of you know of matter
you know the universe would be a single
block okay so hopefully if you have a
little particles and they're square
squarish like that you know cubic like
well then you have to tell me what
separates one cube from another if not
space
what is that
stuff that separates one cube from
another you have to identify that and
this fellow doesn't believe in space but
he doesn't tell us
what he proposes instead
okay that's where we have a problem
okay but he continues and he says the
following he says
what is making a single oxygen molecule
stay in location until the window hits
it and drags it along yeah that's the
question we want to understand that
question do you understand the question
and he doesn't because he has the
structure of the atmosphere
okay and let's see what he's got in mind
there are other molecules radially in
all directions providing resistance and
support to this single isolated molecule
so he says the molecule is surrounded by
gazillions of molecules so this is the
molecule right he's got all these
molecules all around it that hold it in
place that's what he's saying okay more
or less because obviously there is some
motion but in general it doesn't move as
fast as the molecules which are hit by
the
glass in the back of the van that those
molecules are moving faster because
suddenly the car hit them or struck them
or you know came and get up against them
the molecules that still have not been
touched by the glass they're standing
still right now and he's saying they're
held together
you know held in place in that place by
all the other molecules in the car
that's what he's saying okay keep that
in mind without the structure of the
atmosphere with molecules surrounding
this isolated molecule it would
naturally fall down as it would have no
supportive medium of an equal or greater
density beneath it
okay he's talking about beneath he
hasn't mentioned anything about the side
and then he
makes it even worse for himself he says
five weeks of me repeating the exact
same thing
yeah this is now the sixth week and
still he hasn't understood the question
let me show you what the problem is with
him understanding the question if eddie
says
as he's saying
that the molecule
of uh
air right or atom of oxygen it doesn't
really matter is being held by all the
other molecules of air okay
well then we would have this situation
and i only drew a few of them there okay
it would be held together in place like
he says by all the ones that are sitting
on the bottom of the van and those that
are hitting already in contact with the
back of the van so these molecules are
not
uh sitting exactly standing still
they're all moving around but relatively
in their old
region okay they're not moving widely in
the van until the van accelerates okay
now we're going to accelerate the van
but see if there all these molecules are
what hold
the red molecule in place then when the
van moves it's going to take them with
them all of them it's going to take the
red molecule as well if it's like he
says that all these molecules hold it in
place
it's the same situation that i had the
other day with the pencil if you put a
pencil because it's solid well yeah the
band is going to push the whole pencil
every molecule of the pencil and here we
have the same situation here you have it
standing still he's saying the molecules
are holding it in place and when the
band moves it should move all the
molecules at the same time
this is not what is happening okay this
is not what is happening what is
happening is that that molecule stays in
place while the other molecules are
moving what is happening is this let me
show it to you okay
this is what is happening okay let's
see it in uh motion here okay here we
have a tree okay and we have the van
moving all the atoms at the same time
this is what he's saying that the
molecule is being held in place by all
the other molecules well then they
should all move together and this is not
what we see what we see is that little
red molecule stays in place while the
others are moving what we see is this
essentially here it is okay
you see that it's moving one group of
molecules at a time while the others
stay in their place
okay you see what's happening here
it's not that they all move at the same
time all the molecules of air no some
are moving while the other ones are
standing still and here let me freeze
one frame so that i can make my point
this is what we're seeing okay we're
seeing that a molecule the the van is
pushing the molecules in the back
to which it's in contact with okay
and those are moving the other molecules
but meanwhile you have all these other
molecules which are more or less
standing still in the same region
waiting for something to push them
forward
okay that's the situation and israel
doesn't understand that he says all the
molecules are held in place by all the
other molecules well if that were the
case then they would all move
you know uh
as a single group okay and that's not
what we see
or that's not the theory at least he
might have a different theory he's got
to put it out there
okay so this is the issue
okay so let's go uh
uh slowly here you know
here we have um a fellow who says you
know just added that it says whoever
said the air in the car was standing
still everything on the planet is moving
at hundreds of thousands of miles per
hour with respect to the center of the
galaxy motion is always relative again
this guy is completely out of whack
he doesn't understand what the context
is the context is all molecules are
moving no one is saying that they stand
completely still especially air okay so
they're moving but
some molecules are moving faster than
other molecules why because the band is
pushing those molecules and those
molecules are pushing others and others
and others down the line as the band
accelerates
but until until
until
the van pushes the molecules which push
the other molecules some molecules are
standing still
waiting for the other molecules to be
squashed together and push them forward
that's what's happening
meanwhile these molecules are more or
less standing still in the same region
waiting for something to push them
this is what these people don't
understand so we got to go very slowly
here because they six weeks they still
don't understand the question they don't
understand what they're supposed to
answer obviously if they don't
understand what they're supposed to
answer they can't answer the question
which explains in large measure why no
one has been able to explain gravity in
mathematical physics well these are flat
earthers all of them from mathematical
physics all the way to you know the last
guy in in the flat
world
okay so here's let's go slowly
what did i do the other day uh i think a
couple weeks ago
we have a tree
and we built the van on top of the tree
by mistake
by design we don't care okay the point
is we built the van or the van is parked
on top of a tree somehow the tree grew
underneath it okay that's the situation
so the tree is stuck to the ground
whereas the molecule of air is not stuck
to the ground
neither one is touching the van neither
the tree is touching the van any part of
the van neither the molecule the only
difference between the molecules i mean
they're both inside the van
but the difference between the molecule
and the tree is the tree is stuck to the
ground obviously whereas the uh molecule
apparently is not
okay that's what we have in front of our
eyes okay we understand that so far
now the band's going to accelerate
what's going to happen to the tree
what's going to happen to the molecule
well hopefully the tree remains behind
right
but does the molecule remain behind
the answer is yes the molecule also
remains behind here it is okay
so here it is again okay this is where
we were
and now the van moves forward the tree
stays behind
and the molecule stays behind
so we asked the uh people we said well
why did the tree stay behind and people
say well because it's stuck to the
ground that's why you know it's not
touching any part of the car
but it's stayed behind because the
stuck to the ground
okay so we all pretty much understand
that right the question is why did the
molecule stay behind what is it stuck to
and here people say well the issue here
is that there is no force
that came up against the molecule
that was not the answer they gave
to the tree they didn't say there's no
force that pushed the tree they say the
tree is stuck to the ground that's why
it didn't move they didn't talk about
force there but now they're saying a
force
uh did not touch the molecule that's the
answer they give you everybody gives you
that answer
the first problem is the word force is
not
a physical object okay so you can't say
that a force did not push
or pull on the molecule you can say a
horse stick maybe that's what they meant
you can say a horse did not push on the
molecule or pull on the molecule you can
say a car a tree a chair a rock
you know you can say any of those
physical objects did not push the
molecule but you cannot say a force
because a force is a concept
okay
so the people who fed them these lang
this language force
uh were the mathematicians and that's
the language these people use to try to
communicate their ideas and so they say
a force did not move it okay
so we can't say a force you can say
that a
paddle did not hit that uh molecule then
we all understand it okay paddle is a
physical object
okay so we have that situation where
the tree stays behind the molecule also
stay behind you say well i understand
why the reason it's um
stay behind as the tree is stuck to the
ground the molecule is not no force came
and pushed the molecule that's the
answer they give you
okay let's do it differently let's do
the experiment a little differently so
that we get to the bottom of this thing
little by little seven weeks eight weeks
we'll get to the bottom of this okay so
here we're going to build the van this
time on top of a different kind of tree
the tree is just lying down there or
maybe
the van just parked there on top of the
tree okay
so so that's the situation it's just
parked there
so we have the tree and it's not stuck
to the ground now it's also inside the
van
most of it like the particle is
what's going to happen when we
accelerate the van what's going to
happen to the tree which is no longer
stuck to the ground what's going to
happen to the particle which is not
apparently stuck to the ground
okay that's what we want to find out
well more or less this is what probably
is going to happen
you know the van is going to advance
and the tree is also going to remain
behind together with a molecule
and so now why did the tree stay behind
and you know you can't say it because
it's stuck to the ground
so what are you going to say
are you going to say that no force moved
the tree is that the answer you're going
to give there was no force until you
know the van hit it you know until then
no force hit it so is that why the tree
did not move
see before the answer was it stuck to
the ground now the answer is well a
force did not move the tree what do you
mean a force
what force kept it there
that's the question
and this is where people have a problem
because they don't realize that you
require a force
to keep it there
okay just like you require a force to
keep the molecule there
both require
something to keep it there and that's
something newton and galileo and all
these other people never discovered they
said well a a particle moves or a thing
moves a mass moves right
as long as something doesn't stop it
or changes its course that was the idea
that they had
what about something standing still
doesn't require something a physical
entity to keep it there
until
a
force a horse right moves it until a
thing comes in contact with it and moves
it
don't you require something to keep it
there
yeah it's known as gravity
see it's gravity that kept the tree
there
underneath the car when the car moved
it's gravity whatever gravity is right
density
mass
inertia whatever word you want to put in
there
that's what kept it there that's what
kept the tree there
and it's the same thing that keeps the
molecule there even if it was the only
molecule in the in the entire car
okay so we have the molecule and we have
the tree and they're all both standing
there because something known as gravity
inertia whatever you want to call it
kept it there what we need to answer is
what is gravity what is inertia what
physical mediator what physical thing
mediates gravity that's the question
that you have to answer
and people say well no until the force
hits it you know forget about that we
don't care about that we wouldn't know
what kept it there
and you can't say a force kept it there
the force of gravity because that's the
what we want to answer we want to say
what is the force of gravity what
mediates the force of gravity that kept
the tree and the molecule staying there
until the van hit them and move them
that's the question
okay
and so yeah we do have an answer
obviously here it is it's that what
keeps the molecule in place is that the
molecule
is bound to every atom on earth every
atom on earth is bound to that molecule
so even though it has some movement yes
it does move it moves very little until
the van accumulates all these particles
and pushes them all forward when it
accelerates
okay so the molecule is pretty much
standing in the same region until
something hits it why is it standing in
the same region because it is bound to
every atom on earth every atom on earth
is bound to it
and you say bill that's nonsense you
know
uh i don't see anything
so there's nothing there what do you
mean it's bound to every atom on earth
and once again i gotta pull mr muller
out
professor muller from berkeley and
people
may be sick of hearing him but i'm gonna
put him one more time because all these
people are so ignorant that they are not
listening again they should listen to mr
mueller here he goes listen carefully
okay here it goes
what's the force of gravity on me
it's the pull of the earth
on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with this big mass here and you have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
okay
so you're pulling on in and everything
is pulling on you
did you understand that
apparently some people still don't
understand what that and nobody i know
people don't understand because no one
even raised the issue here i'm putting
that on there nobody commented on that
not a single flat earther
see if they would have commented and
said look i don't agree or for this and
this reason they made a case
no one even addressed the issue so i put
it on there they're listening to it
but
uh it's like everybody skirts it you
know goes around it goes
uh way around it you know they don't
want to address that issue
and so all i can do is show you one more
time
uh tonight when you
go to bed
please say the lord's prayer the lord
builds
prayer okay here it is
every atom on earth is pulling on every
atom of you
you are also pulling on it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through
things
okay if you can understand that you have
understood gravity
the cause of gravity
and the other thing that you've got to
understand about that is that since we
can't see or touch
whatever is connecting you to every atom
on earth
then you have to conclude that the
mediator is invisible and intangible
it's known as numena you know you have
phenomena and pneumonia
are things that
are of the mind you can only visualize
them you can conceptualize and say look
this is probably how mother nature does
certain things with invisible intangible
things
things that we cannot see or touch
but that's the way we can explain
gravity
otherwise you have to say action at a
distance
and that is known as black magic
okay
okay so let's go on with some of the
questions comments people made here we
go
you stated a wave moves in only one
direction absolutely yeah you show a
surfer riding on a ocean wave and say
the wave only pushes okay
i live at the beach and can see water
being pulled out
when catching a wave i can feel my body
being pulled by the water towards the
way
is that so
question is my experience that a wave
pushes and pulls an illusion
well it took this completely out of
context okay that's what it is he
doesn't even realize that okay and yeah
waves water waves waterways okay we
weren't talking about water waves that
was an example just an analogy okay
showing that the wave pushes the
surface towards the beach there's a wave
pulled backwards yeah of course it does
okay
but we're talking about something else
and again he took it out of context and
so
uh he gets 10 minus points there okay
here it is okay
the context is gravity and light
transverse waves okay we're talking
about transverse waves you know what
those are fella
not ocean water waves because those push
and pull but what are space-time waves
how do they pull how do they even push
okay transverse or logiternal which
which ones are they here you have on the
right hand side upper right hand side
there transverse waves are slow and
longitudinal waves are fast okay they're
faster than transverse waves which are
the worst kind of waves to
to simulate light with and today we're
simulating them with transverse waves
and here at the bottom you see a
comparison you have longitudinal waves
which are like sound okay
and those are faster than transverse
waves but that's just the least of our
of their problems anyone proposing
transverse waves doesn't realize that
what you're staring at is vectors
mathematical vectors what are vectors
they are
just um arrows that represent magnitude
and direction okay
and uh yeah there you have uh two black
holes they're colliding okay
and this was uh confirmed uh by the
mathematicians uh a couple years ago
they won a nobel prize for saying look
when the two black holes collide they
send all these waves outwards well what
kind of waves are we talking about i
mean uh
if they're going outwards how do they
pull
i mean if the wave comes outwards along
space time how does that pull on you
that's the question they have to answer
okay and then uh how fast they travel i
mean if they're transverse wave they
travel slower than longitudinal waves
which travel much much slower both of
them than torsion waves okay so torsion
waves is the fastest wave that
man is uh
has experience with okay
and torsion waves moves along a
mediator such as a rope okay here's my
rope okay torsion wave
you know
not only as fast but it goes along a
mediator rope like media dna like
mediator what does a transverse wave
move through and they say well it
doesn't need a mediator
uh to move through but that's the
you know that's space what is the thing
that's moving
what mediates light itself okay that's
the question these people have to answer
they get confused and they talk about
the mediator through which it's
traveling it's like saying fish travels
through the ocean but a fish doesn't eat
an ocean through which to travel
great no problem so a
fish can travel through space empty
space nothing no problem
but you have a fish
you have to have a fish in order to have
travel and so the question is what is
the fish in the case of the photon in
case of light that's what you have to
identify and to say nothing is traveling
well you know nothing has a difficult
time traveling you know you have to
identify the object here that's
traveling
okay and then it's just to make sure we
rub it in okay here it is longitudinal
seismic waves reach you 1.7 times faster
than transverse waves and you can see
why the
transverse wave has to go up and down
where the other one just moves along an
axis okay so that's
the reason
uh longitudinal waves travel faster that
means that sound should travel faster
than light if light is a transverse wave
okay so
bad uh way of simulating the worst way
to simulate light is with transverse
waves okay
it's the slowest wave known to man and
the fastest one is torsion okay torsion
doesn't move anywhere it just twirls in
place
you know it's in the same place it's
just in situ
okay so here you see the traveling wave
what is it a bunch of vectors okay
that's what you're staring at magnitudes
and directions so this is
so realistic okay they have all these
uh arrows indian arrows that represent
magnitude and direction they're moving
uh it's a mathematical contraption they
call it a mathematical object or
whatever they call it what you're
looking at is nonsense that's that's
nonsense they try to illustrate
a mathematical concept that's what they
did
again they reified a mathematical
concept a bunch of and it's irrational
anyways because you're talking about
magnitude and direction
and bunch of them and they're moving
now a torsion is is a rope it's a thing
okay so you're talking about a rope
dna-like rope pair of twine threads
and it's torquey we're done that's how
easy it is that's how fast it is there
you see it okay much faster than a
traveling
transfer suede
okay and
so um
what was the context the context with
this you had the uh
earth
uh flying out of the solar system if the
sun were to disappear and here you're
gonna see the waves coming out of the
sun when the sun disappears a long space
time so how fast do they move are they
moving in one direction if they move in
one direction
uh how do they pull i mean if they're
gravitational waves how do those waves
pull
and and again they have this outward
going thing moving along space-time
which moves constantly because all those
waves are being created constantly by
the sun even when it is there so the
oscillations a long wave uh space-time
are there anyways
okay so
if if they move they move in only one
direction how does a wave that moves
outward pull inwards that's one issue
how fast do they travel
and then how does it keep
you know the earth from flying out
before it disappears
okay so too many too many problems with
the
uh gravitational waves
of general relativity einstein didn't
believe in them by the way he wrote a
paper against those
okay and uh here you have another file
says you state that the speed of light
is constant yeah absolutely
since
always travels at c little c okay
since albert i mean einstein proposed
this
uh start taking measurements and come up
with different speeds
uh well uh idiots did okay they're known
as idiots yeah and not physicists i was
told the speed of light became constant
for the equations to work
uh
actually it's the other way around you
know little c
is used by general relativity but
general relativity uses warp space and
when you have um
uh you know the little photon traveling
along a curved surface in other words
it's curving what you have is angular
momentum angular momentum
has to increase the velocity and what
they've done is just change the
direction and keep the velocity constant
so it's cheating
actually if you know space time is
curved like they say
light would have to travel faster and
faster and faster if it's going in an
angular momentum
uh direction if it's changing its
direction okay but the way they cheat
the mathematicians they bring the
physics part which is direction
and that's what they introduce into
angular momentum and say well you don't
have to increase the speed because what
you're really doing is just changing the
direction
so the speed dream in other words
the velocity is the same but what
changes is is the direction direction is
a physical concept velocity is a
mathematical constant speed and velocity
and mathematical okay and that's what
they do they cheat
okay so a mathematical solution was
devised uh
well we got i got to say something about
that their measurement was fixed by
distance traveled in a vacuum
could you explain or clarify yeah i can
clarify very easily you know there you
have it you have a given set uh length
of rope you can call it a meter whatever
you've got there
and if you torque it more and more and
more and more well you have more or less
the same amount of rope okay and that's
a long story to explain why it's almost
the same
but you have more links
right
frequency
and each link is shorter
wavelength okay
so with the rope you can explain
frequency in exchange for wavelength y c
equals frequency times wavelength is a
constant little c is 300 000 kilometers
per second it's a constant and it's a
trade-off between frequency and
wavelength and there you can see why
with the rope rope is the only thing in
that imaginable
that can simulate you know can
model
c equals frequency times wave which is
been amply verified and here you have it
you know the more you torque this rope
the shorter the links and the more links
you have more links frequency
uh short earnings wait done we're done
see how easy it was but we get uh a
bonus on that and that is that you get
this as well
you get that uh you know why einstein
concluded rightfully so that the
velocity of light is independent of the
movement of the source
if you turn your light on
while on a train
you don't add the velocity of the train
to the velocity of light the velocity of
light remains 300 000 kilometers per
second whether the train moves stands
still or moves at a
close to the velocity of light it
doesn't matter the thing can move as
fast as it wants once you do not add the
velocity to your flashlight and you say
how can that possibly be so
physically from the physical standpoint
how can it how can you explain that
you would think that you know
like
if you throw a ball while you're on a
train
yes the ball you have to add the
velocity of the ball to the velocity of
the train that's not the case with light
how do you explain that from a physical
point of view and here's the answer the
answer is very clear the uh
rope uh is made of the same material as
the atoms and what the atoms do they
slide along the rope while eating up the
rope
so if an atom approaches another one
like you can say that's the
train atom or the flashlight atom the
one that's moving there
it it doesn't add to the velocity to the
torsion on the rope which is always uh
at the same tension which is always
little c three hundred 000 kilometers
per second what you're doing essentially
is um moving the atom along the rope and
it's eating the links as it moves
towards the other half
that's what's happening so no you do not
add the velocity of light to the
velocity of your flashlight in this case
the atom there represents an atom of a
flashlight
um
what it is it just slides along all the
ropes that are everywhere around us
invisible intangible ropes
no it's not a concept a rope is a
physical object it's a pneumonia in
other words pneumonia
meaning it's not a phenomenon phenomenon
means visible stuff pneumonia are
invisible stuff that you can only
conceptualize it's a mind object you
have to visualize it it's the only way
to conceptualize gravity otherwise you
won't be having any success at all
okay and here's another file he says
does rational science now acknowledge
the empirical observation of black holes
if yes do they undermine the law of
conservation of info and energy i don't
know what conservation of info and
energy is no such monsters in science
okay
energy is a concept we don't conserve it
we don't put a little bottle and
have you know uh keep it for later on
and same with info information you can't
conserve it okay uh i tried putting some
consent
com some information a little bottle
very difficult cosmology refers to an
observation of the movement of galaxies
towards a great attractor is this
considered valid empirical physical
information yet to be explained by
a physics model
well again black hole is not a thing
there's no such thing as a black hole
okay why because as i explained in the
past black hole is zero dimensional
proven by mr chandrasekhar he won the
nobel prize for proving mathematically
that a black hole has no size no nothing
it's zero dimension
okay
and so um
you know there is no such thing as a
black hole black hole a thing is that
which has shape black hole doesn't have
shape we're done
uh science we have no laws so i don't
know what this fella is talking about
when he says laws uh we don't legislate
we don't have a legislature a congress
an assembly and nothing like that okay
so i don't know what he's talking about
uh infra energy are concepts so we don't
use those in science at all
uh
they're irrational concepts okay
especially energy when they say they
transfer it
when you move when you begin to move
energy you know you're in trouble it
means you've had too much to drink
physics does not conserve concepts again
okay no jars to conserve these concepts
and physics um
we don't empiricize anything and we
don't gawk okay so those are the first
answers to this fella's question okay
just to answer the main ones there the
the structural ones the foundational
ones okay
okay but uh here it is this is how they
discovered the so-called first black
hole and it's important to see
how how these people
convert their opinions into science and
say oh we've proven it okay
and here it is okay this is the first
black hole cygnus x1 this is how it was
discovered in the 70s i think 78 maybe
71 i can't remember now very well okay
but here it is okay what they did they
uh they inferred that there was an
invisible black hole that was influenced
signals x1 what they said they pointed
their telescopes or whatever
devices they had to this star out there
and they saw that it was moving okay
and it was moving
like that like in a circle and they said
but there's nothing there and so by hand
they put something in there and they
said there must be a mass
and so they put that mass in there and
they say oh there must be a black hole
and it's rotating around the black hole
and so we've proven
that cygnus x1 is a black hole okay so
that's how they proved it they inferred
it they inferred it
that there was an invisible object that
they could not see or touch right
and they said there is this thing and
called a black hole and because it's a
black hole it's got a lot of mass and
that mass is compelling this visible
star
to move in circles around it okay so
this is how they proved okay the
existence of black hole
and they said what else could it be
that was their reasoning they said what
else could it be if not a mass
out there and start moving around this
enormous invisible intangible mass that
was their whole reasoning
okay so how do we explain it okay in
rational science okay same black hole
okay this is how we explain it
we if you put a charge ball in a
magnetic field it's going to move in
circles
gonna
total around and spiral around that's
what it's gonna do okay we you can do
this in a lab okay
and uh so i'm not gonna show that but
just take my word for it uh put a ball
in a magnetic field it's gonna charge
ball
it's going to go around and spiral
around
okay if you can see that you can look
that up on your own okay
here you see it that's what a black hole
is here you have the galactic magnetic
field it's sweeping downwards and there
you see it on the upper left the little
ball going around in a magnetic field
that's exactly what's happening in the
case of a black hole it goes around and
around nothing because there's the
magnetic field of the entire galaxy
that's sweeping down
or up it could be right uh in that
region
that's what's happening to that star
okay so it's a magnetic phenomenon has
nothing at all to do with gravity
okay so that's the first issue but we
got to clarify something else and that
is that a black hole is alleged also to
suck
the um
gases from a star neighboring star okay
they claim to have observed that and
here you can see an image here you have
the star suddenly its gases are sucked
into nowhere
and it turns out it's sucked by a black
hole
that's what they say they don't see the
black hole but they see the
stuff coming out of that star all that
mass
and all that
gas
and it's going somewhere it's going
where it's going to the black hole
that's what they say they don't see the
black hole but they say it's going
somewhere and they say it's a mass
that's attracting it and we call that
mass a black hole okay so that's
their in inference okay again okay here
it is
one more time
if uh you have smoke in a little lab
okay just like we showed you know the
little
chart ball going around in spiral now
we're gonna see
smoke
being captured
by a magnetic field what is known as a
magnetic field here it is okay you can
see the smoke
and a magnetic field is drawing all that
smoke in swallowing it up
and that's what we're saying is
happening in the case of the star
here is the smoke on the bottom right
okay the being sucked by the magnetic
field and there you see the other
smoke okay the gases of a star being
sucked by
a ledge black hole what it is is really
the magnetic field of the galaxy sucking
the uh gases from that star so the gases
so the magnetic field is doing both
things it can suck the gases out of a
star and it can also compel it to move
around nothing because that's what a
magnetic field does has nothing at all
to do with gravity so we're saying it's
a magnetic phenomena
now just to show you another possibility
okay we like to show this as well could
be two galaxies neighboring galaxies and
a star that's being affected
is being um pummeled by the magnetic
field the threads you know that are
going around the galaxy because these
are magnetic threads as we call them
these threads are sweeping down on these
on these um so-called black holes on
these regions where they see a
star moving around nothing or a star
losing its gases and we're saying the
confluence of two
um
uh magnetic fields of two galaxies that
could also be the case and that's why
they're singled out as stars that move
around nothing and that are losing gases
okay so these are possibilities that you
got to consider you got to ponder them
under the rope model
okay another question common people say
stars are made mainly of condensed
matter thus it is uncollapsible so
they're saying
stars cannot collapse because they're i
guess made out of a single
piece
that's essentially what this fella is
saying or suggesting
and so here we take the view of the
establishment okay we agree with the
establishment a star
if you were to go to the center of a
star
uh you would see
tremendous reactions okay in there in
the center okay
it's a
fusion going on in there okay but what
you see there this is the official
version and that you see that um
atoms
are
traveling at great speeds
and they're hitting each other striking
other atoms at great speeds and what
you're talking about is maybe hydrogen
atoms four hydrogen atoms and they're
trapping at such great speeds that they
fuse to form um
helium and so that's what a sun does in
the center it turns four hydrogen atoms
into helium and it releases the excess
energy that's the official version
okay
and it uh here you see a diagram of that
you know you can see the center of the
sun
okay
and this is the same for any star and
what you see is four hydrogen atoms are
at your uh left side and they collide
and they turn into uh
two hydrogen atoms um
together with one hydrogen atom they
form this three
h
helium okay three helium and the heliums
then uh
combine to form this uh helium
molecule for helium uh where it it kicks
out um
on the other side you know they kicks
out hydrogen two hydrogen atoms okay so
if you do the math of this it comes out
right but what they're saying
essentially that four hydrogen atoms
fuse
at great speeds to form a helium atom
we have a problem with
uh
not with the fact that it's a fusion
process that we totally agree it's a
fusion process that's going on inside
the sun that's why the sun is almost
eternal five billion more years they say
they calculated uh that probably have no
problem we have a problem with speed
okay
we have problem with velocity we're
saying that the atoms hardly move at all
in the center of the atom they are being
compressed together okay so here's the
quantum version essentially okay this is
what they're saying
that as the uh
star collapses on itself which this guy
doesn't believe in okay the uh atoms are
still moving at great speeds okay and
what they're doing is colliding against
each other and forming helium
we say something totally different we
say this is what's happening it's being
compressed
into helium so when you go into the
center of the sun you will not find too
much motion okay what these atoms are
doing is just being compressed squashed
together
so there is no such thing as speed the
fusion process inside the sun is a
question of squashing atoms together not
one of velocity of or speed
and the other thing we need to mention
here is that you know we cannot
reproduce this here on earth because we
don't have the
pressures necessary
uh to simulate what's going on inside
the center of the sun
okay so this is this is the issue you we
have no way of reproducing pressure here
on earth what they can do is accelerate
particles which they do in their
colliders
if they if they're really accelerating
particles right
making them collide at great
speeds and they say oh if you make them
collide yeah we can build
uh
helium from hydrogen and that's why
that's the theory they have for the sun
and again the only thing i want to
mention is the official version is speed
you have acceleration uh of these
hydrogen atoms four of them fuse
uh through speed to form a helium atom
we're saying that's not what's happening
what's happening is they're being
squashed together because there's hardly
any room in the center of the sun all
these atoms just keep compressing
compressing compressing and the guy
who's stuck in the middle gets four
atoms get converted into helium and the
energy that's released
is threads that are coming out thread is
coming out a great
um
what is it
frequency in other words many threads
uh or many ropes many links of rope
are coming out okay so what it is the
squashing
triggers the
rope to
shorten the links and these links are
high frequency and that's what comes out
of the sun eventually to the earth okay
so it's along the ropes uh all we're
doing is increasing the frequency
on the ropes
when we squash the atoms
okay and here we have action at a
distance seems to me a as a mistake from
an experiment
a misconception silly mistake
uh well you know uh we have to look at
the cause
of action at a distance where did they
come up with this the causes of action
at a distance and here i'm giving you an
idea okay
uh they have to do a lot with uh the
fact that they never defined the words
property okay
and so these are some of the causes that
i
came out on top of my head irrational
definition of the word object
okay that's that's where it all starts
because if you think that
it's c touch well then you got the wrong
definition you got an irrational
definition not all objects can be seen
not all objects can be touched on the
other hand all objects have shape so
obviously the universal property of
shape and not see touch
and so the rational definition is
that which has shape
and that means that you not necessarily
will be able to see or touch
an object okay
and
that means that action at a distance is
simply a case where you have an object
that you cannot see or touch not one
that is not there
that's the difference okay because these
people say well i can't see it and touch
it so it's not there that's the wrong
conclusion it's an irrational conclusion
based on the wrong definition irrational
definition
okay the other issue is that um
the
the
irrational definition of science okay
they say it's got to do with experiment
and observation and you cannot
experiment or observe that which you
cannot see or touch
period we're done okay so that's another
uh irrational definition definition of
science or the scientific method okay
if we assume that there is no mediator
you're doing black magic okay you're
you're uh
pinching you know um voodoo dolls
and affecting someone at long distance
that's what you're doing it's called
black magic
okay
mathematics is the movement of concepts
so uh
how do they mediate those with the
movement of concepts so it's a field
it's energy it's mass
none of those are physical objects so
you can't say that's a physical
interpretation of why this object
affects that one from a distance
remote control
and finally you know you have a
words like field wave time energy all
those words those are concepts and so
when you have the movement of concepts
what you have is
black
magic
that's what mathematical physics is all
about black magic
they call it philosophy when they can't
answer the questions
okay with that we'll see you next sunday
and hopefully i can get uh my son ans
and we're gonna
be there together we'll see